faltan pocas horas para que terminen las
negociaciones aquí en la cop 27 y
todavía no se ha alcanzado consenso en
los puntos más difíciles el primero de
ellos es la creación de un mecanismo
para financiar las pérdidas y los daños
que deja la crisis climática una
solicitud que han hecho los países menos
desarrollados este tema ha unido casi
que por primera vez en un solo bloque a
las naciones del sur global por su parte
los países desarrollados impulsan en
cambio un programa de mitigación y dicen
que es necesario hablar de medidas mucho
más amplias que el mecanismo de pérdidas
y daños ante esto el secretario general
de la ONU Antonio Gutiérrez se reunió
con el presidente de la Cup same sucre
al finalizar el g20 Gutiérrez hizo un
llamado para más acciones Aunque sí
reconoció que hay una división entre el
sur y el norte global Gutiérrez invitó a
los negociadores a trabajar en tres
áreas cerrar las brechas en emisiones de
gases el efecto invernadero actuar en
finanzas y reconstruir la confianza como
aumentando las ambiciones y trabajando
en pérdidas y daños al respecto
hablábamos con Vanessa nacate activista
ambiental sobre si se está perdiendo o
no el momento para discutir esto
no quiero imaginar la posibilidad de que
perdamos el momento porque el continente
africano ya está en la primera línea de
la crisis climática una crisis que no
causamos sabemos que África responsable
de menos del 4% de las emisiones
globales pero vemos uno de los peores
impactos de la crisis climática solo
imaginen la posibilidad de perder el
momento no es una posibilidad no podemos
perder el momento tenemos que seguir
luchando no sólo por nuestro futuro sino
por nuestro presente